من باب التوضيح لانه هذا يعني عنصر ربما
لم نتحدث عنه كثيرا وهو وهو موضوع هل اذا
بدا حساب الاسوار اصوات الخارج
والاحتمالات مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات لكن
خصوصا ان هناك حديث عن ان نسبه المشاركه
كانت عاليه في الاصوات القادمه من الخارج
الاصوات الممثليات التركيه في الخارج
عبد السلام نحن نتحدث عن اربعه مليون صوت
من الخارج تعادل في الثقل الانتخابي اصوات
انقره بالضبط اربعه مليون تقريبا هي
موجوده في الخارج استمرت فيها عمليات
الاقتراع لعده مرات في اكثر من 70 ممثله
ودبلوماسيه موزعه في عدد من الدول الى
جانب ذلك المنافذ الحدوديه هل هي تعتبر
ثقيله لا يمكن وصفها بالثقيله ولكن يمكن
ان توصف بالمؤثره نحن نتحدث عن ثقه
الاربعه مليون يعادل العاصمه انقره ومن
الممكن ان تغير النتائج هنالك استطلاعات
راي غير رسميه ترجح التصويت
للرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان لكن لا
يمكن اعتمادها بالاشاره مع الاشاره هنا
الى مساله ان مراكز استطلاع الراي محسوبه
على جهه دون اخرى لذلك لا يمكن ان نعتمد
استطلاعات الرائعه على اساس انها في الوسط
بطبيعه الحال هذا الفرز مستمر حتى الان لم
يعلن المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات عن انتهاء
عن انت
الاقتراع تحديدا في المنافذ الحدوديه ظل
مستمرا حتى الساعه الخامسه من اليوم على
عكسي ما حصل في الممثلات الدبلوماسيه
ومراكز الاختراع في الخارج والتي اغلقت
قبل ايام من الان